[Music]
honored because Selena and I didn't get
to go to prom and I feel like I'm
crowning this year's prom queen which is
really cool
Francie Ariza stuns on the red carpet
Thursday to present her bestie Selena
Gomez with billboards Woman of the Year
award you guys have been through a lot
this year she's being honored what does
this all mean to you as a woman as a
human being as a friend as a woman as a
Latina actress a fellow Latina actress I
just think it's cool because so you
would think we're both actresses were
both latina there'd be a sense of
competition there there isn't she sat me
down and said you should be doing this
with your career you should be doing
that there's so much support she's
probably my number one fan because she
constantly encourages me to be honest I
think Frances should be getting this
award because she saved my life
what is inspiring about her for you
everything I mean her generosity she's
just genuine and her hard hard work
honestly can I tell you like we she was
in the hospital in April she was in the
hospital and she had to shoot fetish and
she got out of the hospital literally
got out and was traded to hair and
makeup to go finish shooting her work
ethic is just like unbelievable just
watching her grow in this industry the
tough times the good times all of it and
seeing her soar through it because it's
tough it's really tough and she's still
standing and she still has her head up
high and she's been so transparent about
it which is not easy
you
[Music]